what okay so the new valerin agent just
got leaked and everyone's telling me
that I have to react to it you fragile
homies through a solid surface when
they're executing a site or whatever
that's fine double tap shooting this orb
grants you a shield which absorbs one in
you need like a pilot's license to
understand what these abilities do this
is kind of cool I'm not going to lie I
think this is kind of cool
contingency to assemble Prismatic energy
why why did we have to say to assemble
why couldn't we just say like like okay
they put Monty ining valerin have fun
you okay everyone told me that I
had to react to the
[Music]
ultimate what you take this homie to the
goog literally over the years this game
has introduced so much that in
that that like three years into its
lifespan they had to introduce an ALT
that allows you to actually take a fair
gunfight